the SEC filed charges against binance
and its founder CEO CZ which he's known
for the SEC Fells charges against
binance entities and its founder Chiang
ping Zao breaking news the SEC now
filing suit against coinbase in
Manhattan federal court it says coinbase
is operated as an unregistered broker
since at least 2019. the SEC filing suit
against finance and finance U.S last
week for a slew of charges the
Securities and Exchange Commission sued
binance saying that it was operating an
illegal Securities Exchange in the U.S
the SEC is finally cracking down on
crypto and it is going to be a bloodbath
if the SEC wins which they're the
government they're gonna win the crypto
Market in America will be practically
wiped out overnight and that is not an
exaggeration we're talking every single
altcoin probably even ethereum 2 gone
but there is one cryptocurrency that
will come out on top of all this one
coin that will escape the wrath of the
SEC so if you're into crypto this is the
video you need to watch where we're
gonna break down everything for you
there is going to be a massive battle
like David and Goliath you know finance
and coinbase are both hiring the best
sellers imaginable and implementing
millions of dollars to his lawyers and
and fighting against the SEC this is
Mason Joppa by the way he's the founder
of block resolutions which is a giant
Bitcoin mining company he's got massive
Bitcoin mining farms in the US where
he's helped institutional investors on
Wall Street get exposure to Bitcoin
mining and Mason actually spent like
eight hours winning the entire SEC
lawsuits so I thought he was the perfect
person to bring on to help make sense of
all this so sit back relax and get ready
for a Wild next few years
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
when you have a finite amount of crypto
tokens and you're in exchange you know
holding most of the bag you can
manipulate markets so I certainly think
there was some Market manipulation
taking place
on June 5th 2023 the sec's Twitter
account dropped a bombshell announcement
today we charge binance Holdings binance
us and their founder Chong panchao or CZ
with a variety of Securities Law
violations and it does not look good 13
charges were filed against binance some
of them include CZ moving U.S customer
funds into entities that he owns and
then using those entities to pop up
trading volume on his exchange while
also trading against his own customers
Finance was pumping volumes so they were
using their own entry entities to pump
trade volume which looks good for their
exchange binance has a US Branch for U.S
customers and U.S customers are banned
from their International platform but
apparently binus was still allowing some
American customers to continue trading
on binance International and even more
damage that binance offered their own
coin BNB to American users which is
basically like them issuing Apple stock
without registering it with the SEC
Finance solicited BNB which is their own
token and they actually marketed the
sale of their own token to U.S retail
investors and accredited investors so
binance marketed BNB which the SEC is
classifying as a security and they did
not register it unlike coinbase binance
actually is having a major allegation a
major battle the SEC wants to freeze all
of their assets and that would be a
major problem according to the SEC
chairman Gary Gensler there are 13
charges will list a Joe and binus
entities engaged in an extensive web of
deception conflicts of interest lack of
disclosure and a calculated evasion of
the law so basically the SEC is alleging
that bias was doing pretty much every
single Shady thing you could possibly do
as an exchange but on steroids which is
why CC has intentionally kept binus in
the shadows quote clearly CZ has been
lurking in the shadows end quote one
Senator said it's hard to put a finger
on where binus is operating and what
they're doing we're gonna deep dive into
CZ the most powerful men in all of
crypto in a future video so make sure
you subscribe so yeah things aren't
looking all that good for binance and if
any of these accusations turn out to be
true Finance us is probably going down
and who knows it may spark more
investigations into binance by other
countries which would be really bad for
the crypto world and the very next day
after announcing this lawsuit the SEC
announces another lawsuit this time
against coinbase
foreign
the Securities and Exchange Commission
filed separate civil lawsuits against
two major exchanges binance and coinbase
coinbase is the latest crypto Exchange
in the sec's crosshairs the regulator is
suing the crypto exchange alleging that
coinbase was acting as an unregistered
broker and exchange the SEC now filing
suit against coinbase in Manhattan
federal court it says coinbase is
operated as an unregistered broker since
at least 2019. compared to binance
coinbase seems like they were at least
trying to do most things by the book so
the lawsuit against coinbase isn't
nearly as bad as the one against binance
or again the SEC is accusing binance of
doing every sketchy thing under the Sun
but coinbase's lawsuit is still pretty
bad part of the charges are about
coinbase's earn program where you can
stay crypto and earn a yield of like
five percent or whatever coinbase would
make money by taking a spread on that
yield that product itself has been you
know classified as security and since
they've shut down their earning program
but the most important charges also
centers around this the SEC had
officially classified 13 all coins that
coinbase offers as Securities instead of
digital currency 13 all coins as
Securities instead of digital currency
these charges were applied to binance
too so coinbase has been offering
Securities kind of like Apple stock for
example without registering them and
without registering as an exchange
broker and clearing agent with the SEC
which is a really big No-No imagine if
Robin Hood had launched a stock trading
app without registering with the SEC
that's what the SEC is accusing coinbase
off and by this as well but this very
important charge all hinges on that one
little detail that those 13 all coins
are actually Securities and not digital
currency now all coins going from
digital currency to Securities may sound
like a little technicality that
shouldn't matter but this little
technicality is what's going to
single-handedly destroy crypto in
America here's why before whether or not
all coins for Securities was still up in
the error the SEC never made a
definitive decision which was great for
the crypto world because they didn't
have to comply with America's super
strict Securities Law but now with the
SEC finally cracking down saying that
the biggest all coins out there like
Solana cardano and polygon are more like
Apple stock than just another digital
currency something that you buy into
with the expectation of profits based on
other people's efforts all of this is
gonna change if this ruling is finalized
which it probably will be all these all
coins out there will only have two
choices register with the SEC or get out
of America as fast as possible now which
route do you think they're probably
going to take
foreign
[Music]
here is the thing about America is that
we have the strictest laws in the world
when it comes to Securities and finance
there are so many strict rules here that
even if you make just one little mistake
you can get find a bunch of money or
even get thrown in jail on top of that
the Securities laws in America are
rooted in the Securities Act of 1933
which means that these laws are nearly a
century old all these all coins would
not be able to function under these laws
and now that all coins are gonna fall
under these very same laws none of these
all coin creators are gonna bother being
in the US a polygon or a cardano or a
file coin isn't going to bother putting
up with all this when they can just move
somewhere else that treats them better
so if this ruling goes through every
single altcoin is going to flock the
places that have much more relaxed
regulations so they don't have to deal
with the SEC and us-based customers will
be left behind all of these old coins
are based in the Bahamas and in you know
Monaco and in Switzerland very you know
Estonia like very friendly regulatory
places with little to no taxes Hong Kong
right Dubai so why would they ever want
to classify it you know file in the US's
security like and be domiciled here when
they're against it so I think you'll
just see a paradigm shift to see altcoin
offerings in the States you know
disappear and become harder and harder
for U.S investors to protecting them and
the same thing goes with exchanges
you'll see a shift of innovation you
will see a binance U.S shut down in
coinbase unlikely move and other
exchanges follow they'll move to other
countries the US from a policy
perspective can be very difficult to
navigate with all the regular regulation
in place and you can say extra y about
the fed or the SEC and Treasury and all
the governing bodies but you know and
are they corrupt you know that's for you
to decide I won't take a position on
that but they're trying to protect
investors But ultimately the sad part of
this is I think you'll lose a lot of
innovation and the innovation in the
United States and that will migrate
elsewhere you know binance us will go
away what I think could happen is
coinbase can roll out uh subsidiary and
have like a Bitcoin only exchange and
many of the exchange may take the same
Playbook and that and those exchanges
May list only the tokens that aren't
classified as security as of right now
the only legit all coin that appears to
be safe from this ruling is ethereum
ethereum was not listed as one of those
Securities by the SEC but I wouldn't bet
on it staying that way what happened was
the founders pre-mined ethereum so they
like pre they you know before the
protocol was offered by Ico they already
pre-minded tenant tokens you know the
talc became like a billionaire and then
they went off and and sold it so you
know while ethereum hasn't been
classified as security yet I wouldn't be
surprised if it was and a lot of these
other tokens were just um you know the
founders it's like a a game of choice
right um they were like all right we'll
just we'll take 20 of the tokens we'll
sell off 20 of the tokens we'll unlock
you know create some magical Foundation
that releases the you know the other 60
you know and and thirty percent of 61
comes in back to us and then leaving a
50 circulating Supply you know it's just
like people pick number out of a hats
and and but the fact that they raise
capital for the cryptocurrency in the
format of an initial coin offering makes
the security and you have to register it
and that's what they you know the SC
really battles with so that is the
current landscape the SEC is finally
trying to classify the majority of
cryptocurrencies as Securities they're
suing the biggest exchanges for not
registering with them and if all this
goes through binance will probably shut
down as U.S operations coinbase will
probably set up an international version
separate from their us entity but most
importantly all these all coins will
flock the greener pastures and leave
America behind I'm not rooting against
finance and I'm not rooting against
coinbase I think they're important to
the ecosystem and until the credit
they've onboarded hundreds of billions
of dollars and hundreds of millions of
users to bitcoin into the ecosystem and
pushed a lot of innovation
um so you know if anything I'd root for
them but I think it's important that
people do think by the books so a lot of
the learnings that you'll come out of
this is what you shouldn't do if you you
know once you get all this power and
have all this exchange opportunity and
you think after seeing what happened
with blockfy and fkx and and Gemini's
earned program in Celsius that you know
coinbase and finance would really get
their act together and they had that
stuff started a year ago and it seems to
it's a nice thing though to solve
Bitcoin and having it in US dollars as
you need it you know in just a matter of
minutes without coinbase you can't do
that without binance you can't purchase
you know a lot of these alternative
tokens that are interesting but I'm in
the camp you know in general like 99 of
all coins probably will not be
successful so the real losers here will
be the American people because short of
breaking the law and using a VPN to get
on International exchanges Americans
will no longer be able to put money into
all coins that they believe in all
because the good old SEC wants to
protect you from yourself how sweet of
them right go to Vegas and you'll find
an entire city of the generates an old
people League legally gambling their
life away but if someone wants to bet on
an altcoin no no no that's too dangerous
use our dystopian digital dollar instead
so when the dust settles and all all
coins have vanished from American Shores
if Americans want to put money into
crypto they'll only have one real choice
left
foreign
all this Mayhem there has been one
cryptocurrency that has been saved from
the sec's Wrath Bitcoin quote Bitcoin
was not named in the sec's complaints
Bitcoin has been determined to be a
commodity under the commodity exchange
act which means typically the cftc
regulates it end quotes that is rights
instead of being classified as a
security like Apple stock for example
Bitcoin has already long been classified
as a commodity much like gold sugar or
coffee and there's a very clear reason
why you have proof of stake and
peripheral of work so proof of work
tokens are tokens that are backed by
mining so it's people that are you know
I like to think of as commoditized
energy proof of stake tokens are sold
pre-sold usually and they raise Capital
through an Ico initial coin offering and
there's a lot of other fancy versions of
icos like stos Etc and those are you
know investors that are you know buying
in early and therefore can be you know
classified as security right because
you're you're raising capital for just
an asset that you're minting and proof
of State tokens they have their
transaction process through validators
of networks and and staking protocols
and typically the problem with that is a
small number of individuals will control
a majority of the tokens and therefore
have control of the protocol or the
asset itself and that's what a lot of
people fear with ethereum right there
was no pre-mining it was just released
into the ecosystem while Satoshi did a
mine you know a significant amount of
the initial tokens it was open source
and anyone could come in and mine it
right and then you had some of the
really legendary people like Hal Finney
who processed the first Bitcoin
transaction between Satoshi and himself
but the fact that it wasn't offered for
sale through an Ico and is backed by
physical energy
um the government actually made a ruling
that it should be classified as property
and this was a case that took place like
around 2015 I believe and it gave a very
clear future world map I like to think
of it like digital gold but Bitcoin is
the only I don't like call it
cryptocurrency right token that is
officially property so it is absolutely
the safest and absolutely has the most
clear policy behind it according to
Regulators buying Bitcoin is already the
equivalent of buying gold for example so
the SEC can touch it so if the SEC wins
if all coins get classified as a
security the only real Choice Americans
are going to be able to flock to is
Bitcoin one of my key takeaways from
this is while looking at buying a 10
coinbase is that this is this is bullish
for Bitcoin Bitcoin is not listed in
this either these sections if anything
bitcoin's been clearly ruled as a
property it tapered a little bit it had
a slight sell off as soon as you guys
have seen absence come but that's just
because Bitcoin unfortunately is paired
to all these all coins and when you have
General macro or micro events that take
place and I'd say this is a large macro
event you'll see Bitcoin taper but it's
actually shown strength and kind of
maintained and arranged on trading so I
think this is all very passive for
Bitcoin so if you're a bitcoiner and you
see this you have maximalists you have
evangelists you have retail and you have
plebs you know all these different
classifications Bitcoin it doesn't
matter who you are you can walk away as
a bitcoiner knowing that you should feel
good but the biggest winners of this
will be Bitcoin miners
foreign
[Music]
China was home to most of the world's
Bitcoin miners thanks to its Dirt Cheap
electricity at one point china hosted 75
of the world's Bitcoin mining capacity
but then the Chinese government cracked
down China banned Bitcoin and made money
illegal which meant that all those giant
money Farms had to sell their miners for
Dirt Cheap on the international markets
so miners flocked to countries like
Russia Kazakhstan and America and all of
these miners are watching all of this
SEC nonsense unfold with their mouths
salivating rubbing their hands together
but that begs the question if you can
just buy Bitcoin on coinbase or wherever
why on Earth would you ever want to sink
a bunch of money into a Bitcoin miner to
mine just a few dollars of Bitcoin a day
that is what I couldn't wrap my head
around until Mason explained it to me
and let me give you an example of a
typical situation this was like to call
sideways Market let's say we have a year
where Bitcoin just sits at 25 000 right
so and you're buying Bitcoin you know on
once a month your costs every month is
25 000 and you end up a zero return and
well miners actually were making money
because every day our cost of energy
Remains the Same and we're basically
buying Bitcoin at a discount you know
what I'm saying and my machine value
like then stays the same and so I'm
actually winning and I'm actually
accumulating more Bitcoin than you at a
discount and actually reminders make
money in Bearer markets and we make the
most money in Bull markets and if you
can time an investment right and I've
done this before and I've seen the best
players in the space do this they trade
in and out of their machines during bull
markets and they sell the machines for
like 2x more than they paid they keep
all the Bitcoin they mine versus like
okay let's say I bought Bitcoin I made
my 2x well I can 2x on the Bitcoin in
mind and two extra machine on mine and
I've actually research where miners from
2016 to 2020 they beat up hodlers from
2020 to 24 they beat up populars okay
makes sense all right now I finally get
it so if you just buy Bitcoin on
Exchange you only make upside when
Bitcoin goes up in price if it stays
like stack Midland you have another
material or you could lose money miners
actually make money in Bear markets too
and the cheaper the energy if you have
free Power like you know chocolates some
people do in like sovereign states and
utility providers sometimes a very like
one sim power like they could be making
they're profitable with Bitcoin at like
3 000 right cost whereas if you bought
it 26 000 and you got smoked right you
lost 23 000. okay and how would someone
get into Bitcoin mining because
traditionally you would buy a minor
yourself and you set up in your house or
your shed or whatever can you go over
like why someone wants to do that and
why they wouldn't like the downsides
okay so home mining really simple like
unless you have a good like source of
sore battery and like close to free
Power and you already invest in that
it's too expensive the average retail my
you know residential you know energy
rate is about 16 cents the United States
to be competitive on mining you need you
know eight cents or less so like it made
sense you're depending on what Miner you
have you know your your Breakeven costs
on bitcoin could be 15 to 20 000 right
so that therefore if you're mining one
Bitcoin a day you're making money at 60
sense like your Breakeven point is
twenty six thousand so I would rather
just buy Bitcoin than that kiss unless I
was really bullish on the future and I
think Bitcoin was gonna double like but
still like it's just you know it's more
strategically effective to buy Bitcoin
in that instance and these machines they
sound like an airplane turbine they
produce a lot of heat they require a lot
of Maintenance they need to be have
proper airflow they're very fidgety if
they break down you need exports to
repair them and you need proper Cooling
and you need all the above so yeah a lot
of people do like stick these in their
shed and some places do have cheap power
you know that's okay but I think it's
really rare for an at-home Miner to be
successful now some at-home miners have
have been creative and harnessed the
heat that's produced from the minor
teeth or house and that makes sense to
me and there's so many of the you know
you can go with there's so many of these
cool like at-home heat mining setups
okay makes sense so what's the solution
like how do you get around like the
expensive electricity and all the
maintenance upkeep simply I mean unless
you're going big and you raise you know
100 million dollars and go about your
own to build a data center before you
can get exposure by buying Bitcoin
mining stocks like you partner with a
company like myself so blockwork you
know that's why I built it I wanted to
make mining accessible to everyone so
clients can come to us and buy machines
from us we'll host them to you all of
the rewards will go to you we'll bill
you monthly for airG you leverage our
economies of scale with an industrial
contract with pulling from the Grid or
behind meter so we we make your
Breakeven costs low and then we manage
the machines for you we'll repair them
for you or we'll send them repairs we
have all the networks or relationships
and competency to do so we have software
to automate it it actually rolled out a
product that's really interesting that
we call the block we're Marketplace and
that's um it we're first to Market with
this and this allows you to have
liquidity on your Miner and to take
advantage of these use cases I listed
like we're Bitcoin you know two three
x's in price you have the ability to
sell it the block where Marketplace is
super cool basically mesa's firm already
helps investors and institutional
investors on Wall Street get into
Bitcoin mining with his giant data
centers like he wanted to make it even
easier for the average person to get
into this so now with the blockware
marketplace with the click of a button
you can buy your own Bitcoin miner from
the comfort of your own home and have it
instantly start mining for you straight
into a Bitcoin wallet of your choosing
on the blockware marketplace you can see
a bunch of miners for sale you can see
what the miner is the price the data
center location that the miner is
located in the hash rate the estimated
Revenue you're going to be making based
on the current price of Bitcoin and
stuff and there are miners in all price
ranges listed on there right now once
you see a miner you want to look into
more simply click on it and then you can
see the serial number how long it's been
online for you can see charts of the
miners historical performance and once
you're ready to buy a miner simply click
buy follow the instructions and then
that Miner that is already online in
their data center will be instantly
assigned to you and that's it you are
now mining Bitcoin getting all the
benefits of mining that we just talked
about without ever having to do any of
the setup or maintenance yourself you
get to put in whatever Bitcoin wallet
address you want your mining rewards
sent to and blockware will pay you out
every 24 hours as long as you've mined
at least 0.001 Bitcoin and from there
you can also list your money for sale
anytime you want just list it for sale
and then someone else can buy The Miner
from you just like how you bought yours
here's a story of an example of this
product being really useful in June 2020
the s19 which you could have just bought
there was released by bitmain for
eighteen hundred dollars in November of
2021 when Bitcoin you know had its run
up and went all the way up up to almost
70k that machine was worth fifteen
thousand dollars so you had the
opportunity to mine it and keep all
those minor words you know your energy
Arbitrage and if you sold it at the Pico
top making eight extra turn on that
Miner I'm not out here pitching to you
that that's like a common place example
but what I see right now is God you know
I wish I had that software running at
that time because people could have used
this so I'm really excited about it you
launched it six weeks ago we have over a
thousand users already we're getting
we've had over 450 transactions this is
just at my sites for rolling this at
other external sites and we just want to
be the central place and then the
marketplace for people and empower them
to mine Bitcoin and have an easy way to
my Bitcoin and buy miners but also have
liquidity and sell-off and have the
ability to capture one of the you know
the next bull ride and to give people
context like you actually have like a
giant physical data center with a bunch
of these miners in it right yeah so
we've two sites live in Eastern Kentucky
in a beautiful area called the
Appalachians there's about 15 20 000
machines running there I have a full
data center team that manages and deals
with if machines go down and fixing them
and coordinating we have a whole
automated hosting and building system so
if you're interested in getting all the
benefits of Bitcoin mining without
having to do any of the setup and
maintenance yourself you can take a look
at all the miners that are listed for
sale on blockware right now by clicking
the link below I'm a huge fan I think
blockware is like a modern version of
those companies that allow you to buy
gold and they'll store it for you but
this is way better because gold just
sits there while these machines are
generating new Bitcoin blockware is the
paid sponsor of this video and again
this is not Financial advice we're not
registered financial advisors we all
know how risky crypto can be so click
the square on the screen or click the
link below to see what miners are listed
for sale on blockware right now
[Music]